[Music]
celebrities can have a lot of influence
in our world especially online and many
are now reaping the benefits according
to marketing firm media Kicks Beyonce
can earn a million dollars for a
sponsored social media post that's
followed by Selena Gomez at more than
half a million in kendall Jenner at up
to 300,000 Gomez had eight of the top
ten most liked photos on Instagram in
2016
including this ad for coca-cola which
has been liked more than 6.8 million
times making it the most liked post of
all time but you don't have to be a
household name to be a social-media
influencer Jamie wax is here to explain
good morning Anthony the influencer
category is a 1 billion dollar industry
and its projected to grow to 2.4 billion
dollars in just two years in some ways
this is a throwback to integrated
content at the dawn of television but as
one expert told us what's different now
is who can be the pitchman and how much
money they can make with the help of a
photographer and a bottle of cologne
Ryan Clark is essentially the head of a
one-man ad agency is it difficult for
you to explain to old friends family
members what it is you do for a living
it is it is very difficult at times I
think I go by many hats so I can go buy
blogger influencer brand consultant I
can go by creative director
Clark is paid to post photos and curated
videos on social media for brands
ranging from Armani to BMW the Texas
native passed up a career as a medical
doctor to become a travel and lifestyle
influencer I was three degrees in
bachelor's in chemistry at masters and
Healthcare Management psychic masters
biomedical sciences
and completely stopped that said my
tracks and was like I don't see myself
doing this for the rest of my life it
might seem like a hobby but running to
Instagram accounts with nearly 3 million
followers is serious business we have a
set influence over the people who follow
us in that regard that they want to
aspire to do the things that we're doing
or go the places that we're going where
the clothing that we wear so managing
engagement managing my followers
managing my brand placement my
partnerships all of those different
things it's a full-time job and I wish
there were two of me I would probably
make a lot more money if there were two
Clark is one of 17,000 influencers in
the database of four card brands want to
go over the eyeballs are James Nord is
founder and CEO of the company that
provides detailed analytics on it's
legion of influencers to brands and
helps with marketing campaigns tell me
about the dollars that the influencer
category represents so my like very back
of the napkin if you kind of want to get
a sense of what somebody's making and
this is for the fashion and beauty space
100,000 followers on Instagram you'd
probably make $100,000 a year 200,000
followers two hundred thousand dollars
three hundred seven and so forth so
people had a million followers should
quite easily be able to make a million
dollars a year earlier this year Forbes
released a comprehensive list of the
world's top influencers in the field of
Fitness alone the top 10 influencers
have a combined reach of 106 million
followers they calculated top youtubers
can fetch up to three hundred thousand
dollars for a video partnership and at
least a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars on Instagram how much of major
corporations marketing campaigns are now
dedicated to supporting influencers yeah
not enough I wish there was more but
it's it's certainly growing you know
I've heard that it's gonna be five
billion dollars in the next three years
I think global digital advertising is
about 150 billion so it's it's a sizable
chunk one of those companies is Giorgio
Armani Giovanni Valentini is vice
president of marketing
what has changed then what is changing
very fast is techno
the access to data and the different
ways in which we can ask access people's
life and this is where influencer gives
brand an opportunity to respond entually
increase the entry point to engage with
consumers can anyone be an influencer
yes maybe no journalist max chaff gun
would know his first-person account of
becoming an instant influencer appeared
in Bloomberg Businessweek their works
served two reactions one was hahaha this
world is so ridiculous and then on the
other side it was like can you tell me
how to get more followers chaff can
worked with the company socialite its
website says it offers influencers
strategies for marketing talent
management content creation and media
partnerships I got a professional
Instagram photographer to shoot me in
various cool clothes and they coached me
on how to act and I did okay like I
added about 1,500 followers or so over
the course of 30 days so you look at
that yeah that sounds pretty good
except I was spending basically all of
my time on this so I think anyone can do
it but a talent is probably more
important than than anything else but as
chaff confound out even with influencers
whose brands are based on authenticity
looks can sometimes be deceiving can you
buy followers yeah the answer is is yes
you can buy followers and as part of my
experiment I bought 500 followers for 50
bucks or something and very quickly
Instagram deleted a lot of them but they
didn't catch all of them for card says
it's developed an algorithm to detect
fake followers you see he's got 82% of
his following that's that's totally
activity is 15% lurkers and only 1.6
percent
bots but there's also the issue of
transparency it's been estimated 93% of
paid content violates FTC guidelines so
last spring the agency sent out a letter
to more than 90 influencers urging them
to prominently display that a post is an
ad or sponsored content and in June
Instagram added a paid partnership
header
when a commercial relationship exists do
you find that that people are cautious
about that so yes absolutely one of our
first big deals we were able to offer a
beauty vlogger thirty thousand dollars
for a video and I was super excited to
send the offer because it's like it's
kind of fun that's a lot of money to
give somebody to make a five-minute
youtube video and she turned it down
because the shade of foundation didn't
match her skin tone and she said if I if
I do this video all of my followers will
go out and buy this and then I will lose
their trust and I was so impressed that
you could turn down thirty thousand
dollars because I would have I mean give
me that foundation I'll make nothing
yesterday and James Nord says the money
is more than a safe bet even the nearly
1 million dollars Kim Kardashian was
reportedly paid last year just to attend
a party with other influencers and
you're saying that's harder and more
honorable work than most people give her
credit for absolutely absolutely I mean
that's the Super Bowl I mean that's
literally how many people watch the
Super Bowl that are watching her yeah
100 million people that love this one
person and take her advice and respect
her advice and your brand gets to be a
part of that for a million bucks that's
honestly is steel and if you don't have
3 million followers never fear if you
have the right type of follower you
could be what they call a micro
influencer or a nano influencer even I'm
working on nano aspiring tanana I'm
aspiring to nano absolutely big lines
will get you there Anthony everybody
following a follow now pill folks right
Jamie thank